you know when you wipe but it's like you
didn't really
do a good job I have a theory that
you've never wiped in your life
I bet you there's particles of poop and
pee on the end of your hair wait didn't
we already establish that you you wiped
action yeah back to front like the wrong
direction
hold on
she hasn't changed Annie we haven't
taught her a thing yeah she still does
it yeah so you basically haven't wiped
your whole life you just brought the bad
stuff to the good stuff no I don't dig
it in my ass and then bring it out I you
know what I'm saying soft swipe no she
doesn't wipe guys this is faster
pretending she white no but sometimes
when you're in a rush and you don't
fully wipe all the way and it's like
you're still wet but not in the good way
and when you're out of what do you do
when you're out of toilet paper though
but if you wipe you're not still wet
say what you said that you do without
when you're ready oh when we're out of
toilet paper I'll use the um the
cardboard thing and I'll wait that's a
good one that gets it all that's you sit
there and soften it first no I scrape it
out so crazy that you do that I bet you
go in the comments hello I can't be the
only one you are great it's great you
are I wouldn't use it for my butt though
oh but you would it's a hard thing you
scrape see I would scrape the butt with
cardboard but I have done this
um in the Philippines uh toilet paper is
scarce stopping the Annie that's right
we have a new segment all for other
segment I'm gonna up your Annie oh up
your Annie
um so the Philippines toilet paper is
not they don't give it out for free in
like the public restrooms and whatnot so
it's like every man for himself can you
pay for it or it's just not there um
like now they're a little bit better in
like the malls and and stuff but like
growing up like you basically we had to
bring your own toilet paper your own
wipes or you're just literally out of
luck so what I would do I went to an all
girls catholic school towards the end of
my stay there saying shout out to Saint
Teresa's but um shout out our sponsor
hey Teresa sponsor of the Philippines
all girls school friend by none we want
to teach the nuns love us they play us
every Wednesday
let's say look we watched it we checked
it out it it's clean you guys can watch
it you're going to learn a lot of really
appropriate things and so what I would
do because I my mom would not you know
send me to school with toilet paper is
during class
um any time I had like maybe a minute to
spare I would take lined paper and I
would soften it so I would have a stack
of softened lined paper to use as toilet
paper and that's what I used to wipe
with in a crunch
she's like oh my God
that sounds soft softened paper hand
softened paper by kalila like I would
buy that well she can use it as paper
mache and then make a
a mold of her own behold behold behold
the behold but I if you guys are at home
you're in a crunch and but there is
lined paper sitting around are you I'm
telling you just looking at how pretty
she is like what is she talking about
what what
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday and guess
what that's rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
for a limited time neutrophone is
offering our listeners ten dollars off
your first month subscription and free
shipping when you go to neutrophone.com
and enter promo code trash find out why
over 3 500 Healthcare professionals
recommend neutral for healthier hair
neutrophone.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
that's neutralfold.com promo code trash
guess what Rick our listeners get 20 off
their first liquid death apparel
purchase why the the clothes are so cool
why would anyone need even a percentage
off this offer is available exclusively
at liquiddeath.com trash exclusions May
apply that's liquidath.com let therapy
be your map with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com trash Tuesday hi you
guys I am on tour it's called the dream
without a dream tour if you know the
reference
Brittany
um next week are all my shows in New
York City we added one more show so July
19th through 23rd I'll be at Joe's Pub
I'm very excited I cannot wait New York
as my favorite city in the world I can't
wait to see you guys there and after
that I will be at Oxnard DC Boston
Madison Wisconsin San Diego Detroit
Chicago San Jose Irvine get tickets at
astronauts.com love you mean it
hi sluggies I'm on the road welcome to
anniewood tour you can see me my very
exciting birthday show one night only in
Las Vegas at Wise Guys on July 20th I
will be in Greenville South Carolina
July 28th and 29th I'll be in
Philadelphia August 11th and 12th I'm
going to be at the Great Outdoors Comedy
Festival in Calgary with Andrew Schultz
August 27th I'll also be in San
Francisco Austin and a bunch of other
places so go get tickets at
annieletermann.com shows
thank you
[Music]
all like think about is your nipples
yeah I can't get over I can't get over
the width of your neck
so today is the Barbie themed episode oh
wait before
I click the Bell there's a lot of
comments that you're not getting
they're not getting the
episode sent to you great well said very
well I didn't know some mushrooms but
very well articulated I'm on mushrooms
it's the Barbie episode but um click the
bell for the notification is that right
yeah so we're having some algae
yeah click the bell for notifications
and also I would say I'm not too uh
ashamed to say
if you're a fan make sure you're
watching all the way through watch time
is very important in the algorithm and
the algorithm doesn't like us because
there's a lot of men out there who think
we're [__] and they're mad so we need
you guys to help fight them and then
thank you to the nuns at St Thomas
school and Theresa Teresa she said Saint
Thomas you turned it masculine I hate
men or not I'm a pikmi girl
Christian girl what did you guys used to
do to your Barbies how did you play with
Barbie well it was your method of play
let me open the gates real quick I have
to use Skipper because it was the only
one that looked like you [__] you oh
Skipper oh Esther you came as the Down
Syndrome Barbie oh my God you can't say
that just because I have brown hair
anyways I would also want to play with
my Barbies I would like I would fart and
then be like my Barbie farted I have
friends who still bring that up to me
oh I mean I don't know how my parents
thought that I wouldn't I wouldn't show
them on the doll where the bad man hurt
me you know what I mean like all my
Barbies were either decapitated like had
sharpied periods on them had mutilated
breasts like I was it was a little kid a
Barbie you foresaw you getting your
breast implants out
no but you can't give a dead old kid a
Barbie She's she's weird about her body
already she's looking at this like ideal
version of a woman that's like so you
know beautiful yeah I drowned my Barbies
like it was some my dolls got murdered
they went through like well you're just
trying to be like your uncle
see Barbie was my original hot girl like
I worshiped her I wanted to be like her
I would [__] fantasize so hard about
having those clothes that she had they
were so cool I couldn't why didn't you
put them on they fit you I couldn't wait
to be an adult to have those kinds of
clothes that would fit me we should make
you like velcroed clothes or you can
just velcro just take them off of velcro
okay now we have a business
lazy girls
um what about you Ann I bet you didn't
play with you no I bought you no they
did but my mom was like she had a lot of
like she'd be like oh I just don't get
Barbies so then I'd be like all right
and I would have to make them like fight
and like bang my brother's
umen what to make them do like Matt like
I would have to make them like fight and
be like again diddle baby I'm telling
you
yeah I had the pregnancy one too the
pregnancy one no wait Barbie got
pregnant Barbie got pregnant and then
you could just take the baby out of the
stomach she must have had a miscarriage
since it didn't really I wonder if her
baby was the same size as yours well we
didn't get pregnant Barbie in the
Philippines we didn't have 10 years
behind oh my God that's a scary oh
that's not really scary well it's better
than giving her a badge I guess girls
aren't ready for that but look at her
legs thigh gap Barbie's vagina really
messed up men because that's what men
expect now and we expect a nice smooth
Ken doll we expect no penis no that's
why balls are such a shock to us I've
never in my life found
um can remotely attract hell no no Ken
was not hot he always seemed like the
gay friend and that's weird because I
love half gay boys
didn't Ken always see like I say like
they were just going shopping together
wait okay I actually have this this
interesting question do you I to me do
you have a guy or have you ever had a
guy in your life where
I need you to like dig deep and think
about this okay and I just the viewers I
want you guys to know this is no one I'm
talking about that you would know or
that's in our business at all whatever
but like Tony or Redman no no a guy who
like you see pictures of him
but you know him right in pictures of
him you're like he is so [__] hot I
Wanna [__] him like his body is hot
whatever but actually him as a person
and you know him like it could be a
friend or whatever you're just like
it's just not there his his energy his
personality something about him ruins it
but like his actual physical body I if
you took his soul out it would be
[__] it's a great vessel yeah do you
have that that's it I feel like that's
why I didn't ever date Haka I like never
had hot boyfriends until I was a little
bit older because why because I never
liked their person they were annoying I
didn't like that they thought they could
have me too because my older brothers I
always felt like there was this like
power Dynamic my older brother's friends
would like
kind of mess with me and I always felt
like they were pranking me I could never
tell if they're being for real
yeah I mean it's hard for me okay I
think what you're saying is a little bit
hard for me because immediately knowing
how he is in person would I would I
would look at him through that filter I
know what you're saying and I am the
same way but there's a few in rare
instances where I can
I don't know if it like comes to me in a
dream where like I can sort of like find
the attraction but then it's only his
bot it's truly a vessel of him is
attractive
um okay so I can objectively find people
like oh he's you know handsome pretty
but have zero like desired even like I
can't even think about them sexually so
that's different because that are you
saying that is when you see oh I can
tell he's conventionally attractive and
other people would want to [__] him but
I don't or are you saying I know like I
see like oh like that is somebody that
yeah it is different because
conventional attractiveness is
different than finding someone
physically attractive yeah like I just
sort of get lately the whole like how
men just look at us as bodies and
objects sometimes I'm like I kind of get
it like I saw this man running it like
she was like I've been engaged for 17
years I finally get it
I saw this man running in short shorts
and his like thick hairy muscular thighs
I was like
like that's hot I don't know which is
not
it's weird because I don't know that guy
at all well he he's not hot you can see
if they go into like those um like Magic
Mike or going to like Thunder Down Under
like I find it so just repulsive I do
too with that said we should go that
said I have tickets
um I'm actually starring in it
I use my other chest plate I love a slow
burn attraction though where you see
them and you're like you pay them no
mind because you're like oh like that's
not usually my type and then either you
do stuff together you get to know them
slowly and the kind that those feelings
trickle in and you're like wait a second
like like something shifted and why do I
find this person like
you know just like I can't stop thinking
about them that's the best feeling for
me the Slow Burn but that first initial
burst of a try when you see someone
you're like oh he's hot yeah it's so
boring to me I like a slow birth well
you can only go down from there usually
yes exactly
but I think like if I think about me
with Dave like I saw him had that
initial attraction and then almost had
also the Slow Burn where it's like
oh and I'm getting to know you and I
like I think you can have both and no
obviously you're right
I guess we keep like pulling it's it's
hard for me to like go back to all these
guys it's like
it's just it's hard to always pull
because I'm like I have my guy you know
so it's like hard to remember I'm always
trying to remember like when you get
years into a relationship it gets easier
to remember for some reason because
you're like oh I haven't I have nothing
and there's nothing not too much about
you
um wait side note and I do mean this as
an insult to you Annie
um I cannot believe how lucky we are
that we like the person that you're
ending up with yes I cannot believe well
I can't believe I found some I can't
believe it like the odds of you ending
up with a guy that we all hate were so
high oh that oh you're saying that you
guys like I think was about even myself
I was like oh my God because I was
thinking about it I was I did um
uh the new show on your mom's house the
um first date and she was like asking
all these questions it was so hard like
I wish I had like been more prepared
because it was hard to remember but
um I just was like she's like what are
red flags I'm like I I don't I never had
red I dated people I hated for years I
would date like I would just stay with
them forever well that's what the Jewish
Matchmaker says she's like date them
till you hate him so oh I would date
them about three years past hating them
I mean I'd be like I used to sit in my
car when I would come home because I was
like I don't want to go into my house if
my boyfriend would come home I would see
him like his car pulling up I would just
turn the light off and pretend to be
asleep even though he saw me turn the
light off wait that's literally what me
and my dad joke about when if a relative
is gonna come by the house we always are
like okay we're building a Panic Room
we're turning all the lights off and
that's what you did for your voice
like he just stays the light turn off
I'm like oh I just happen to fall deeply
asleep the second you came here and he
starts ripping pillowcases because
you're not gonna give up the [__] that
night he was he was like angry but he
was like he kept it in more he was a
different one but he um yeah I just nope
but he was here and and when I [__]
him I had I did have to think I would
have to get a crush on someone else to
really bang him hard
I'd have to be thinking about someone
else and he was fine as handsome big
dick I just I just couldn't he hated him
he hated his insides yeah
no yeah and it's not his fault do you
how do you do you just have to close
your eyes or turn the lights off for the
other person sex it would be close eyes
yeah yeah and I'd be like don't talk I'm
trying to pretend you're someone else
like
I actually think it would be I mean role
play is basically saying that I think
it's cool to like let's just pretend
it's not anyone but you yeah
yeah if you've been together for so long
like you want yeah it's I don't know I
did that my whole relationship I think
with Bobby I mean he was like Brandon
the Virgin towards the end he was really
shy
he's really thankful
you guys should like sell like a a kit
that's like different roles that you
guys did so like so that like people
couples like me and Dave can like buy
the kit and be like Oh today I'm Brandon
the Virgin it's like you want to [__]
her so bad like the ways you try to get
around having sex with Delilah Esther do
you still want to make oh it'll be like
you it'll be like a mask of your face my
boyfriend will wear it
Esther do you still want to have sex
with me what do you mean I what do you
mean by that
what do you mean by that do you still
want to have sex with me these the
tattoo is fading so I don't know I'll
get a redone
that was the darkest thing I've ever
seen that was like a weird I was like
oof I was happy for you I guess because
it wasn't it your first one yeah
foreign
that I dated in my 20s and he's the only
boyfriend I would like punch in a dick
if I saw him publicly to this day all my
other exes were like were generally like
decent people this guy was not I don't
love where this is going a month into
dating a month into dating like he knew
that I had a whole family trip to the
Philippines planned like when we first
started dating and Christmas came around
and he handed me he's like Merry
Christmas and he had tears in his eyes
and the first gift was an album of just
pictures of him it was like the Andrew
Keegan
um um he sent you pictures of himself
there's an album of pictures of him like
like headshots basically and the second
thing was
a ticket to the Philippines to join my
family and I I did not invite him oh
it's so invasive but did you let him go
he he came yeah but like he he followed
me like everyone's tickets or just he
bought himself a ticket to go he bought
himself a ticket to join me and he had
tears in his eyes I kind of like where I
like this guy's plan
just bought tickets to share with them
so maybe it'll work the tattoo and the
sex thing you know eventually I will
give in okay she's manifesting something
but it is like it's more Charming now
that it's fading the fact that it wasn't
fading for a while was also awesome
we were all worried for a second
our Rising price is stressing you out
if you're looking for ways to cut costs
you need rocket money rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place I just
looked it up rocket money wow a lot of
good reviews that's right I'll download
it now look I have ADD I need it it
helps me I have no clue what I'm
subscribed to I'm hemorrhaging money
left and right and let me tell you what
rocket money will do for you it will
quickly and easily find your
subscriptions for you and for so much
money any that you don't want to pay for
anymore just hit cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you it's that easy
Rick it saves the average person 720 a
year what average person is spending
that much money on stocks a lot more
than that all of us I'm bringing the
average down they trick you you know
they say the 30 days and then you're
right and then it just ordering news for
a year I probably don't even know what's
happening correct wow rocket money also
helps you manage all your finances in
one place and automatically categorize
your expenses so you can easily track
your budget in real time and also get
alerted if anything looks off stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday you don't have this
problem Rick but a lot of us girlies
after a certain age or because of
hormonal stuff you know thinning happens
we lose a lot of pretty strands off our
head I know about neutral they have it
for men too it's not only good for your
hair it's also good for your nails and
I'll tell you something I have a very
sensitive stomach but I'm able to take
these every day and not only do I feel
okay here I feel great in here because
the confidence I've gotten from these
strong nails is thick head of hair and
just overall just feeling like I'm doing
something good for my body is worth its
weight in gold
correct
from postpartum to menopause and no
matter the root cause neutrophil has
four unique formulas to support women
and each is physician formulated using
natural drug-free medical grade tested
ingredients That's What attracted me the
most to it I actually do look at these
things I looked at all the ingredients I
know what they are I feel safe with them
four pills a day baby thicker hair and
what six months it's good that's what I
love about it is that they don't promise
you a quick fix overnight sensation BS
it's the real deal and it takes time and
it works it works if you work it and
you're worth it I've gotten my
sister-in-laws on it everyone in my
family's on it and they have the hair
oils now too take the first step to
visibly thicker healthier hair for a
limited time neutrophil is offering our
listeners ten dollars off your first
month's subscription and free shipping
when you go to neutrophone.com and enter
promo code trash find out why over 3 500
Healthcare professionals recommend a
triple for healthier hair
neutralfold.com
promo code trash at gingerful.com promo
code trash
[Music]
so why would you guys uh I'm curious be
with people that you didn't like I was
scared I think I was so like afraid to
like okay there was two things going on
the guy that I was talking about was
very nice and I had never dated a nice
guy that was like devoted to me so I was
like am I an [__] if I give up this
person that's like so into me or
whatever and so nice to me like he
wasn't doing anything wrong he's a he's
a perfectly like good guy he just wasn't
for me you know and so I was afraid of
that and we lived together so then I was
like oh my God and then he I always date
guys that are from Jersey and then so we
meet each other's family so then you
have to like divorce a family to me it
was just it was basically being like a
coward and not courageous and not brave
and feeling like that feeling that
always you look back on and can't
believe I put that feeling of being like
Oh what if there's not something better
out there which is like insane to think
that insane and even at my age you still
think that when you go through a breakup
but I think to answer your question
fancy like you don't you go in to this
you go into all of your relationships
like liking them at first and then you
just over time like find out more about
them and you're like people are monsters
but he wasn't you know what I think with
mine was different because he wasn't a
monster but I never saw like a longevity
with him and then we just got into all
of these like
contracts and we're like signing Lisa I
was like I don't know how this happened
especially if you're meeting his family
like right so it was like I never so I
think I also it was maybe my resentment
towards him was like less even about him
and more about the fact that I was like
betraying the truth like I knew we
weren't gonna
be together so it was just kind of like
this painful thing where I'm like and I
just like didn't want to hurt his
feelings and it's it really comes down
to like a weird narcissistic thing where
you're like well and like you listen to
people they're like I couldn't live
without you and it's like yes they can
you know absolutely can move the girl
right into my house it was like it was
the quickest thing I've ever seen in my
life have you never dated a girl and
thought maybe three months in you're
like oof like I actually don't like this
person as much as I thought
um
sure but it was a short thin yeah how
short you know what I'm saying like I
wouldn't have uh three years passed yes
that to me since like yeah to both
people but also for yourself right
into to carry 100 and then but also I
think it was a lot of like fear of
financial stuff because we were like we
moved in together because we were broke
you know and then I was like oh my God
how am I gonna afford to it's like
things that in the end you're always
like oh you end up finding the money
like when you do the right thing like
money just appears to help you usually
is what I've noticed when you're not
like betraying yourself and this other
person isn't it wild though how many
boys at least for me how many boys I've
lived with I moved in with at such a
young age like I always moved in with a
boyfriend by the time I was 17. and yeah
what are the chances you're gonna like
stay with this person forever at that
age it's so crazy to do such a grown-up
thing to move in together 17. I've lived
with every single boyfriend since the
age of 17. yeah I I think that that is
normal for me too because one it's
expensive to live two of the best parts
of a relationship are going to bed
together and waking up together it's
like it does feel weird like you're
paying for two runs for no reason yeah
but then I then they then you go out in
the world and you meet so many normal
adults who have been in Long
relationships who still have their own
places and you're like oh I guess yeah
one new thing that I've been seeing too
which I kind of find kind of cool is
like I have friends who are married with
Children who are both busy successful
people who don't live in the same
household or even live in the same
country it happens a lot with like
people that I know in Asia where their
husband works in Hong Kong and the girl
has like an entertainment career in like
the Philippines but they're happy they
have children oh my God she has all
these like hot Philippines I know she
definitely does who are these Filipino
entertainers you know I grew up there
you guys I could have been one you still
can be R yeah but um so I and then I
have um I have friends in New York
who've been together for almost 15 years
and they still don't live together and
there's they're a great idea but I love
being like every time I'm on the road
because Todd's been working now and so I
he doesn't come on the road with me and
I cannot wait to just like get in bed
with him like it's like I just want to
be like cuddling with him all the time
he's like has his like work room and
slash reptile room there's so many
reptiles now it's like really kind of
crazy I mean to come out as like a red
tile guy right before we get engaged
just like so I can't die I [__] like
you think he's been but it's actually no
but everyone I try to talk [__] on him
with about it is like oh my God what
kind of reptiles tumbling came into my
house to meet the skink like I was like
I thought we'd be trashing himself you
know what I used to have because I had a
big terrarium as well do you know that
I'm a reptile girl myself I've had I
wouldn't be surprised I had a tarantula
named Boris not a reptile I had another
one named Charlie it was a desert
tarantula but I had two green bass
clicks what are those those are the ones
the lizards that walk on water when I
lived in Vegas so I had oh my God that's
such a perfect place to have a terrarium
exactly and I also were you selling Coke
too there's something about owning
reptiles I'm like should we just start
selling Coke
and I had um three ferrets I was like a
fool and they stole stuff right don't
ferrets steal things from you ferrets
are so cute and they back their asses
into a corner to poo they never poo out
in the open they always have to back it
into a corner so their poo stays and
they are like I know well because in
Vegas you can have more there's more the
exotic animal laws are a little bit more
relaxed less did Dave have to check that
out before anybody did you to come with
them
but like one time Dave and I went to an
exotic animal pet store in Vegas and it
was like I met a hedgehog for the first
time it was really I really won't but
they're released did you do a DNA test
we were a match we met on 23 minutes
we're actually using the Hedgehog's eggs
to have children are you gonna do eggs
no you're in such a good health Journey
right now it's such a but do it you have
to do it I don't I'm very well you don't
have to I'm No I'm I'm
I'm really on the fence like I've been
very anti-out freezing but then lately
I'm like uh is this a mistake I don't
know I'm so curious how Kourtney
Kardashian got pregnant again definitely
through IVF yeah definitely didn't bang
it out I was like so annoyed by how
obviously that was not her telling him
for the first time that she was pregnant
oh yeah I mean obviously but it's like
it should have been yeah that was a
fantasy they sold us like she was and
then you see how much you're showing
like you wouldn't have noticed but she's
like but you saw it it said she was
recreating a moment from his music video
oh is that what it was yeah which I'm
like it was I guess it was something no
that's cute yeah
but you just blink and you forget all of
the blink 182. my policy though is like
you kind of only get your first
pregnancy to like be a big deal and then
like once you keep having kids after
that it's like
do we really have
what do you think that if you get
pregnant again you're not gonna be
well that would be I would count that as
my first yeah okay okay another one you
would count your miscarriage as your
first no I will if I do choose to get
pregnant again which I'm really every
day is I don't know
um I would probably consider that my
first would you be like so weirded out
when your baby came out with like scales
on it if my baby doesn't come out as a
dog I'm throwing it away like I want a
dog baby so badly or I'll take a slink
or a skink what is a skank well you look
up a blue tongue skink is it the
double-headed ones no double-headed what
the [__] Lila no the skinks where their
butts look like their head so that if
the Predator bites accidentally bites
the butt it's like a defense mechanism
it's like a
I didn't make this up I swear you know I
you know you say that Todd became a
reptile guy like later in the game
um look
um
ours is really fast okay that's like
obese his name's Arnold we just named
him today oh so cute can you look up the
doubles did I make that up I'm his
mother double
yeah oh my God I think
I love Todd
no it's really cute but every time I got
to town he gets a new one I'm like Todd
you guys named him after my accountant
so the first one
um see the second picture the butt looks
like the the head so that
um if the prep no not that one these are
so that one I would love to have a
little Siamese you see how yeah it's
like a full turd
does that not look like like a you know
what it looks like it looks like a
ferret backed its ass up to squeeze that
out
can you believe we all poo hey
Kyla's like I'm trying to bang you can
you
I can't believe I've never seen Esther
poop in our friendship really you I feel
like you're a little bit are you a
little like shy in some I don't think
I've even heard you fart I for sure uh
done it on FaceTime with you Annie and
I've seen you yes yeah we do have a
thing at home though where I don't
and I don't know if it was always like
this or if this is newer but I don't
close the door and Dave will like walk
into the bathroom and I'm like private
time and he's like this is what doors
are for he gets so mad at me no you like
to be asserting the boundaries having
the boundary be there I want a
cheeseburger a verbal experience Bobby
used to do this thing where because
he I was just so secretive about again
private time
um I just don't in the decade we were
together like he never saw me not once I
don't think he ever really heard me fart
ever did you start doing it he never saw
you yeah
um but hiding behind those tits he would
barge in and then inhale really hard
like like this if he knew even if I was
just peeing because at the chin the
chance that I was going number two like
he wanted to know
like my scent or to humiliate you yeah
and I'd be like things happen words
would definitely go against everything
you asked him
I do that with donut like I love the
smell of her farts they're so small and
cute
so maybe you're like his donut
maybe like they just maybe they they
want what they can imagine Esther
sniffing Donuts ass
I do just I mean I know we do this every
episode but I just love my dog yeah dude
I just love him I'm sick sometimes I
just will call my friend Mary Lou I'll
just like leave her a message I'll just
voice memo her and I'll be like my dogs
cute I love him so much it's like she
probably just like oh I just I don't
know why I would send it to her this is
crazy that like you've never looked more
Pam Anderson but also you've never
looked more Joe Rogan at the same time
like the with the neck
yeah what if I just pulled my I was bald
I was Rogan the whole time
I'm on it
what does Todd make of the titties
he doesn't want me to wear them because
he knows I it brings me discomfort he's
like oh the boobs again I'm trying to
get them off like start passing out I'm
like allergic to whatever it is but it's
worth it if if these weren't so
difficult and such a burden I would be
wearing these every episode show me
episodes I could have
used these for
dude I'm kind of similar I I'm pretty
sure I'm allergic to like wetsuit
material like the neoprene
like I always anytime I have to go dive
I get these like weird patchy bumps all
over my body that are so itchy
I wouldn't know I've never had a
swimsuit I've never can't wait to shove
you in the water wait okay so I have
sort of a controversial topic I want to
bring up and oh my God before people are
like start calling me Pro pedophile
we're having a discussion for
intelligent people oh my god with me and
Annie yeah oh my God
no it's not it's not related to that I
had this written down before okay I saw
this girl being interviewed and she was
talking about and I was trying to like
find out who she was and I literally
couldn't she was talking about how she
was dating a guy who would
take her shopping make her buy little
girls underwear he would buy her
coloring books and toys and little girls
clothes it was you the whole time
this is no this is you like trying to
get us off the trail you're like this
girl I couldn't find out
my friend uh her name is Mester
um and then like so then she would
like they would go to his place whatever
and she would like this is I just wanna
I should give like trigger warning I
guess to you guys no like this is a this
is a disturbing topic and it made me
uncomfortable but so then like
she would like color in her coloring
book and then essentially like act like
a little kid and then they would engage
in sexual activity and I didn't really
give a sense about how this girl felt
about it so this this discussion isn't
really about that situation just made me
think like it made me really sick to my
stomach and like uncomfortable when I
heard that but then I was like well what
if you are someone who is born as a
pedophile and you are attracted to
children and then instead of like
molesting kids you yeah acted out in a
safe way like is that okay is that bad
are you asking your ex-boyfriends or
well
um we had Martin it's just okay to have
a crush on you now at 35 you finally
look like you're 19. thank you like what
if you were with someone
hey this is I know it's your job do you
think that someone's going to need to be
a baby with my voice and [__] but let's
just say Grandma finishes come to me and
you know what is
Annie and I are not um I don't read
childlike we're not targets for petos
anymore
we were I do feel the very strong
necessary urge to say I've never had
been approached about this either
although one guy once was like you
should wear all white cotton little
girls underwear and I was like what no
um anyways so no one I've ever like had
no one has ever like asked me to do this
but I am thinking of myself here
what if you had a partner that asked you
to do that and in this girl's story I
don't know how she felt about doing this
so that's that's why I'm saying like
let's separate her and now this is a
different discussion but like
if so and I know you're saying no one
would ask you but what they might like
what if they did
had me wear like like Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday and I think that I would be
okay with it if it was like a one-off
like he was just trying new scenarios
and he was like okay today we're this
character but if it was an everyday
thing of he really wanted me to be a
baby girl then no like I just like
pedophiles are like actually very sick
like Twisted they were born wrong and
they need to be like
sent away yeah I would check his
computer like yeah but to be like sent
somewhere so even if they're trying like
do you know what I mean like to always
be fighting that urge to do something
that's so
I hear you and it is such a danger to
society but like
what are they supposed to do and I'm I'm
like are they allowed to enact it in a
safe way with like
they're like okay I wonder what's you
could put your Pigtails in now ma'am I
wonder what that's like though like
imagine being a parent right and um you
you follow you know you love your baby
he's a sweet boy he's kind and then
um you know nothing about his sexual
preferences or urges but only to find
like later on like let's suppose at 19
that he's found out about all his like
you know child pornography and his
computer like that is a really really
like sad thing to go through because
you're probably like no this kid is good
yeah what do you do well that's like
there's like he's been shooting at the
school and you're like oh my God they're
like it's your kid
when Randy's mean to this one dog that's
how I feel like oh my God my son's the
shooter
I feel like parents know when their
kid's the shooter that they're like
yeah that tracks didn't our guy played
the shooter and he did Ezra oh our guy I
love how he's our guy these are they
so wasn't he and we need to talk about
what's the I never saw that movie it's
such a dark movie
um we need to talk about Kevin wasn't
that Ezra Miller
I think he's our guy just because we
send we just send each other every clip
of him
yeah
that's so funny because I just asked
Dave to explain to me who that person is
and he did and I still don't there he is
so you've seen the perks of a Wallflower
right no I read the book the movie's
really sweet like is it black and white
he's a really good actor
um but he um started acting up getting
arrested I think he lived in Hawaii for
a couple years like just causing a whole
lot of [__] and then but he's also
non-binary so all of these articles
about him being so disrespectful to
people they're like they threw a chair
in a woman's head and it's like pretty
funny and like they're so careful about
it and there was some weird situation
where he might have groomed a young kid
or was in contact with an underage child
but then Hollywood has apparently
forgiven him in the last two weeks so
now people are like wait what the [__]
because the flash is coming out and
they're like this is too much money
basically
basically forgiving all of it because of
like mental health reasons oh okay right
so which is you know
yeah
we gotta forgive guys
what we don't forgive we carry
you may have noticed there's a crazy
beverage brand out there and it's called
liquid death listen so you guys if you
guys ever see by the way because they're
really Obviously good at branding if
they can make water this cool have you
seen their clothes oh there's yes oh
their merch is so good sometimes I like
to wear their clothes on a night out
sometimes I just like to wear them
around the house either way it might be
cool but it's definitely comfortable
what I like about my liquid death
apparel is not only is it priced right
so I feel like oh I'm getting expensive
clothes I also know that it's within my
budget but unfortunately they don't have
any deals you have to pay full price
though that's not true anymore
20 off their frequent death purchase by
going to liquiddeath.com trash who knew
water could taste so good in aluminum
cans you guys and did you know that
plastic bottles aren't actually
recyclable they just get sent to
landfills even if you put them in your
recycling bin because they're not
profitable to recycle liquid death
donates a portion of profits from every
canceled to help kill plastic pollution
oh and do you know they have Iced Teas
now only 30 calories 6 grams of Premium
30 calories per sip no no no no
they're delicious or you would think so
but no for the whole can I literally
love the the Iced Teas that they came
out with my favorite is the armless
Palmer they're so good like thank you so
much for yeah and something about
drinking armless polymer makes me think
I'm getting refreshed on Halloween any
day I want you can find liquid death's
healthy beverages on Amazon or at a
retailer near you and trash Tuesday
listeners get 20 off their first liquid
death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquidjet.com trash
exclusions May apply that's liquidat.com
trash this show is sponsored by
betterhelp look we obviously all need
help very much better health a lot of
help I know I need a lot I need better
help
better it's uh look
things have been crazy in this world
everyone's depressed everyone's anxious
everyone's going through stuff
am I thinking yeah I just don't like to
speak for other people but I will say
one thing I can can see we are in a wild
world with what's happening in Russia
and Ai and you know AI keeps up at night
I mean my sometimes my Alexa will just
go way out
technically yeah yeah I love to do it
again
it's not a song Some mean ex-girlfriend
did that what set that up because you
can set your Alexa to do things so if
that would just happen and is this gonna
hey pretty boy you wake up and then it
goes rain sounds
you can set people's alexas on this ad
too jeez you guys if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule Rick huh just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
right I hope my sister is listening
that's better help
hclp.com trash Tuesday
foreign
have you guys ever
um met someone and you're like oh I'm
not attracted to them maybe this we
talked about this oh my God full circle
but then you do something super bonding
that involves like hours and hours of
like just having to spend like intense
time making an Ikea furniture maybe or
anything right like for me it's like
diving right and also getting out of an
Ikea
like oh my God how the [__] do people
get out of there I don't I cannot
imagine I've gone out of there as many
times as I have it's a freaking maze
it's so scary I panic all the time yeah
go to the Salt Lake City uh airport is
the same [__] thing I want to play
hide and seek in on Ikea we're not
finding you
I I I this is going to be a story of
Esther sleeping over
and Esther's she's hiding let's get out
of here
but then you're like oh my God like is
there like a weird vibe but and then you
start to think there is no if there
would have never been a Vibe had we not
like had this like bonding experience
like what can you give an example of the
bond like like diving say for instance
she's basically telling us she fell in
love with someone that's not what I'm
saying maybe look at her face what the
hell so like not shiny she glow who is
this person she's pregnant who is this
are you witnessing us no he was just a
friend and how annoying would be if she
ended up being the pregnant one I would
not be annoyed I would be so happy are
you kidding yeah I would keep the baby
now oh my gosh yeah I don't care who
knocks me up I'm keeping the baby you
hear that
[Laughter]
one one
um no we I mean I'm too I I'm too old
for an abortion I can't yeah oh God I
mean I'd be surprised if I could if yeah
if I'm not pregnant that's right anyways
okay so yeah like I I spent like
six hours in the water but it was like
really intense there was no vibe it was
very like friendly but then like
afterwards you're like huh like why am I
thinking of this person and I think the
same thing for him where it's like it
was so just platonic until it wasn't but
I think it's because of the activity I
think the activities I wasn't seeing you
as a system
he was going oh maybe if we dive
you think so yeah
yeah so I think he probably would have
followed you into a submarine
risk it all wait can we talk about this
I know
we need to talk about the fact that we
are predicting catastrophe I we should
really not talk about anything anymore
we're not we killed Ray Liotta who wants
to be cool well you killed your ex oh
the boy we killed my finger guy your
finger guy airplane finger guy
I will say I killed billionaires you
guys I was one of those girls who I
basically talk about not coming up for
error that was me with the submersible
news like I had no life for eight days
or whatever well it was it was like
obviously tragic but it was like Tiger
King in a way it like brought us all
together it was so thrilling I also like
it was sad though God no it's so sad I
for sure but I would I would go down to
see the Titanic I would
no you're nonsense we although I will
say that that death is not a slow death
that like yeah high pressure death is a
very quick you're out of there
so maybe maybe I hope you have solved
his Rubik's Cube
you know Dave had never seen Titanic I
made him re-watch it with after the
thing yeah he'd never seen it Titanic
cells soared but they did no it did
Celine Dion's I My Heart Will Go On like
made it to number 12 again we are such
this seems like a movie
yeah well it's just this is this is the
power of Titanic the story is That's The
Power of of uh Esther King what did they
think of the movie well so he first of
all this is the most our age differences
ever showed because Titanic was in
theaters in 1998 and that was the year
where I was 10 and he was 20. and I saw
that movie in theaters five times I was
in love I was obsessed and Dave was a
cool too cool he was in Harvard he was
but he was too cool he thought it looked
so stupid and cheesy and he was like
this movie sucks and you never saw it so
I'm like we have to watch it
so you're saying he was single okay he
didn't have a girlfriend I was like we
gotta go watch Titanic I feel like he
did have a girlfriend which is weird but
it was like a Harvard girlfriend they
were like ooh you want to play Scrabble
but so
he first of all I will give him credit
like there are there's it the movie is
cheesy but he did admit that he liked it
and it was obviously all cheesy movies
are great yeah the cheesiest part is
like one of the worst movies and it's so
good is it really one of the worst oh
it's so bad they die together come on
yeah when I re-watch that it's and like
he's just like where we fight that's
what we do and then it's like raining
that's so ridiculous I know when I look
back at what I also Jack Dawson is gives
me the ick like he's not a he's a broke
loser he's pulling her away from a good
provider like she Billy Zane yeah she's
[__] up her whole life she won't even
get on a Lifeboat because of Jack Dawson
and man she's known for three days you
know what a blonde man you know what I
was thinking the lowest men in our
society blonde men I was thinking about
how you were definitely gonna get on the
Lifeboat because you look like a child
and a woman
I thought about the other day I was like
she was on that Lifeboat I can get two
seats now also what if they found out
you were Jewish what would happen
I they would
they'd be like stay in the kitchen
[Laughter]
but
um also the saddest horriblest part of
the movie is when like I literally I
don't think I would I know I sound like
a liar I would not be able to get on a
Lifeboat and leave behind Dave or my dad
like it could not do that my mom's dead
sister's gone no are you kidding my mom
is on the Lifeboat bye sweetie she's not
even smiling just like no very matter of
fact do you know that when I was growing
up we went to the movies me my mom and
my dad and all of a sudden the theater
started to fill with smoke
just sort of filling with smoke fast
this is a final destination one of my
favorites and I look my mom gone I'm a
kid I mean my dad were like what the
[__] she literally left without us well
did I tell you guys did I tell you but
then it you can't take two so you need
you needed your mom to do that to
relieve you of like when you knew you
were already gonna pick your dad if you
have to you know what I mean wait I have
definitely done this what do you mean
um and this is when I knew for sure that
maybe the boy that I was with I didn't
really really love we were on vacation
and the hotel like fire alarm went off
and I don't I'm not one of those like
you know Mosey slowly like I If an alarm
goes off I'm out I'm not taking chances
I don't care if it's a drill I'm getting
the [__] out of there and I'm driving my
car the [__] away from there like bye
I'm not going back to class I'm not like
no no you'll not see me for the rest of
the day if it's a bomb threat it's there
is a bomb there and I'm out I think
that's smart yeah I'm walking I'm only
one running and everyone's just like
it's just a you know whatever like I
don't give a [__] I'm out goodbye
um but
um we were on vacation and the fire
alarm goes off at five in the morning I
run down like several blocks away from
the hotel in a big t-shirt on my
underwear and left him well I'd have to
turn into a porn nothing but a t-shirt I
was thinking about the Jessica Simpson
song Wait I always think of her just
being completely bottomless with just a
t-shirt like when he poops yes I'm so
sorry but I just realized what you would
be doing on the tide Panic as it sings
what would I stand up
is hilarious
you the band you'd push them aside and
you'd be like I got this guys any
anniversaries any birthday it wasn't
wasn't Kathy Bates that character no she
got on a Lifeboat and she wanted to go
back she played Molly Brown she wanted
to go back and save people but the guy
rowing the boat was like we'll get
swamped and we can't do that Esther's
only seen three movies but she's seen
them so many times I know everything
everything I've also watched a lot of
documentaries this past week like okay
wait so the saddest part of the movie
that's so sad I don't even know why I'm
talking about it but we did try to make
it funny is when they're saying goodbye
to the daddy he's like I'm getting on
the Daddy's boat and he's saying goodbye
to his daughter so me and and me and
Dave were just like Frozen in in sadness
and we've been joking all week like the
Daddy's boat is coming and it's gonna be
like the man show there's gonna be like
strippers
daddies but will be even better You'll
wish you were on it all right can I I
wanna I wanna present a new topic okay
hey I realized and maybe this will help
with your dread topic a little bit I
realized
I am in a rush all day long and I was
like this is completely self-inflicted
and I think I want to do a challenge
where I drive the speed limit for one
week let's see what happens it's the
most pathetic have you ever driven wait
you're elderly have you ever driven the
speed limit yeah I'm pretty I'm a
grandma driver but lately I've been some
kind of a speed demon it's I don't know
if I can do it it's so annoying to ride
the speed limit what about you always
faster oh I'm speeding I'm I'm at top
speed all time do you ever get a ticket
no
I haven't gotten a ticket either I got
one speeding I just gotta use the
breathalyzer
take it out was that a euphemism for
blood yeah oh I got it okay cool wait
I've never blown a cop but my my there
was a cop in New Mexico who got in
trouble for blowing you laughs
they called me the breathalyzer back in
college no he got in trouble for like
banging people that he pulled over oh
yeah his own his own camera caught him I
don't know if somebody pulled over if he
was just like cheating on his wife or
whatever but it was bad he was on duty
and I like looked it up and I was like
oh my God that's my friend I know that
cop
oh it's my favorite I feel I know his
kid that feels bad wait you know what
I'm not I you guys are probably forced
me to go to this but
um my high school reunion is this
weekend no yes no right I'm yeah yes I
regret not going to mine we have the
internet we don't need we already know
who got fat no no I have the best
Counterpoint we're too reliant upon on
the screen digital [__] we need more
in-person experiences I think we had
different high schools okay so I'm with
Annie if I'm if I'm returning to my high
school let's just say it's the last day
that school's around
I'm with Annie because I'm gonna be like
Drew Barrymore and Fire Starter
so high school was horrible for me like
it was sad like people call you know I
mean I was like it was horrible reason
for you to go look at you you're a
gorgeous no but it's you don't they just
but not showing up as the coolest move
you let's be real okay wait yours was a
10-year your dread is that you can't go
back to high school that's true I missed
my 10-year I missed whatever has I had
has I had 15 yet
oh my God maybe I don't think you're
allowed to do that boys
so why did you regret it [__] that was
baby talk you sick [__] wait that's a
thing you know like baby talk is like a
trauma response apparently no we all
better listen I baby talk when Todd
tries to trick me to Baby Talk on live
when I'm doing lives and it's so
embarrassing when you can do it to baby
talk in public it's so embarrassing but
I do it I mean I baby talk everyone in
my family maybe not my mom I thought
baby talk is like a sign of safety I
don't know I read it differently so I
was like I thought breastfeeding your
mom still is oh wait that's what I
wanted to tell you guys I breastfed a
boy and
um like it it was part of like the role
play thing and I I it was so weird and
amazing what has been going on since we
last saw you wait why didn't this come
up with the child muster thing we did
with it I think I forgot is this the
diver guys
no it wasn't nothing happened by the way
with that other guy like is it gonna
happen she's in love she's yelling at us
no oh she's mad
you love him I don't love him no this is
like in Hercules when the girl's like I
Won't Say I'm in Love I can't you think
I know Hercules that's what you think I
know but have you sat there and done a
whole muscle
dork it's so funny you guys have never
like I just really the fact that I've
found a job in bullying you it's like I
was born to bully theater majors and
you're such a theater major
yeah
the fact that we have this it's very
special I want to thank you letting the
dreams come true wait can you just try
it with Todd when you get home and with
Dave what sit him on your lap I'm not a
baby tiger
can you just try it yeah
you know I want to know how this
happened
how did you get there
um led up to it it was there was nothing
sexual like we were just in bed together
he came in in a bonnet
I have a problem with that the strap
comes down and he just like grabbed you
know like just he just grabbed my my a
cup and
and then I was like you want it and he
was like Mama he did the whole thing and
then it just turned into this whole it
like we didn't have sex afterwards it
was just him we were watching TV and he
was like sucking on my tit for like 30
minutes if we had kids would you want to
have a kid do you think what do you we
got pregnant would you catch it
what do I want a kid if we got pregnant
would you want because she's like I was
catching it she's it is a catching thing
you caught it last time you caught
pregnancy I'm like hit or miss you know
you think you caught it because a lot of
your friends from your TV show oh yeah
100 because of doll face uh and then
that there's the season ended and you're
like I'm the only one that hangs out all
the time
no but it was like Shea was pregnant and
then Brenda was talking about we were
all talk it was like the hottest women
you know were getting pregnant yeah I
know you've already worshiped their
existence holy baby fever yes but I'm
really curious about this non-sexual it
wasn't sexual
afterwards the guy yeah competition
who is this guy who are we talking about
he didn't die okay die for guy and
breastfeeding guy are two different
people breastfeeding guy breastfeeding
guy is somebody that I was seeing that
I'm no longer seeing title of the
episode who is breastfeeding guy
question mark question mark he was just
really sweet I don't know it was nice I
didn't and then nothing happened
afterwards it wasn't sexual we were like
okay we got up it wasn't sexual no but
it was just something to do again I
think he might have been taking it a
different way than you yeah
I'm not having sex with diver guy I just
said well you no you are and nobody even
said anything and you just brought it up
again no no I we know you're not because
we know you want it to be very slow
yeah she doesn't want to be a fast
that's a merciful death
submergible I keep saying
wow like I'm very curious about diver
guys I'm I'm ready for kalila to get
pregnant too soon guys come on how about
my going on how about Bobby in like two
weeks how about my parents no be
pregnant on that that's funny yeah
pregnant on it make Bobby deal with your
pregnancy
oh my God maybe no we're going on
vacation just a family like not not
lovers you guys are so weird what the
[__] [__] it's [__] so sweet family
it's my sister's 40th birthday and he
asked if he could come I'm like of
course you can come where is it to the
island oh really yeah when is her
birthday
um the second are you staying in the
same room
um do all three of you sleep in the same
bed oh me Jules and Bobby no your sister
and and Bobby and you
because you said you always sleep in bed
with your sister and we know he's living
by the Bobby there is a picture of us
and then Rudy sleeps in the bed too
Jesus Christ there is a picture of Bobby
in the middle of my sister and I like
sandwiching him in bed but that was just
for the photo that wasn't like you know
we don't do that usually that's like
such a hot Asian family style what six
foot their little sister howdy sister's
in bed no you're sick you've never had a
sister have you got molested kid with a
doll
you Dom Lester you're sick you're sick
please like play this video three times
through click the notification Bell like
we are desperate and also we know that
you guys are who truly get us we know
that you'll hook us up and help us out
with the algorithm comments whatever the
[__] we love you and we'll see you guys
next week with a brand new episode bye
hmm
[Music]